seen the difference that I can make so
whether as governor it was being able to
go to a new kindergarten that was being
built because of work that I had helped
lead and seeing the excitement on the
faces of those five year olds as they
went into that public kindergarten it's
working with the students here at the
Kennedy School and at Harvard and seeing
how idealistic and energetic and
optimistic they are about their futures
and thinking the world is in good hands
because we've got those future leaders
who are committed to making a difference
well I think they're there are a lot of
them now one person that I always talk
things through with is my husband and if
I could go to somebody to talk to them
about a difficult problem I think my
first choice would be Abraham Lincoln I
think for Lincoln to have been able to
believe strongly enough in keeping the
Union whole to be able to see so many of
his constituents die in that process
must have been so hard that I think his
knowledge and his values would be
something I would really love to to hear
him talk about it's been wonderful to
read some of Doris Kearns Goodwin her
recent book team of rivals which talked
about Lincoln and how he dealt with
people and and how he was able to keep
things together through what was just an
awful time for this country
based on looking at what he did with his
cabinet I think he might say to people
forget about those differences and think
about bringing the best people in to
help solve problems and certainly that's
what he did and I think we would be
better off for that